it only took 11 days bipartisan
criticism and serious health concerns
from mayor Pete to finally respond to
the disastrous train derailment in Ohio
toxic cancer causing chemicals spewing
into the air after a 50-car train packed
full of hazardous materials veered off
the tracks earlier this month homes were
evacuated and authorities started a
controlled burn that set off a massive
plume of black smoke just days later
people were told it was safe to return
to their homes but now there's
disturbing reports of animals dropping
dead and people getting sick
the home should have been cleaned
um from the you know from the onset
these people were being
marginalized in an effort to uh to
mitigate this this is the first time
I've been here in a week and I was here
five minutes and I had I had to have a
headache right now and you can smell it
that anyone who comes here who hasn't
been here can smell it if it's so safe
and okay then why does it hurt
Buddha judge making his first public
comment about it last night on Twitter
he could have brought it up during an
event yesterday but instead made jokes
we've faced issues from container
shipping to airline cancellations now we
got balloons that's right
um
okay why are these people of
infrastructure where you got a
neighborhood often a neighborhood of
color that finally sees the project come
to them but everyone in the hard hats on
that project looking like uh you know
doing doing the good paying jobs don't
look like they came from anywhere near
the neighborhood
okay all right so they keep saying it's
so safe it's so safe so why doesn't
Buddha judge who just decided to talk
about it almost what 13 days 10 12 Days
Later why doesn't he go visit the site
if he's so concerned it was just a week
ago tonight that President Biden gave
his State of the Union speech and a big
portion of it was about the Forgotten
man right and he was talking about labor
unions really that's what he was trying
to get at but what about these people
and they really did feel forgotten for a
week and where is FEMA right why aren't
they on the scene right away the
Secretary of Transportation
I I understand having a lighthearted
moment at an event but this is really
serious I had a friend of a friend reach
out on Sunday night and say that um and
I think you had it on last night where
the fish are turning up dead in the
rivers well that should portend that
there might be a very serious problem
and so unfortunately for the people
there I think they're in for the Long
Haul here but because of this attention
maybe they will be able to get some
place safe where they can wait it out to
make sure that it is going to be okay to
be there because we don't need long-term
health effects on top of the fact that
their lives were just upended well you
know Greg in addition to all that you
know we have a recollection of 9 11 when
I think it was Christy Todd Whitman came
out she had been the EPA director uh and
then the governor everything is safe
everything is safe and we saw what
happened then the shame of it is this is
in a poor area it's in a minority area
and nobody's really talking about it
until Governor wine today got up and
said it was outrageous yeah can't blame
them because they're busy mayor Pete is
busy he's got some pretty big issues
that he's dealing with for example did
you see what he said about construction
workers that it's really a problem that
their skin color doesn't match the
diversity of a community and that's
really got to upset people I remember as
a kid walking around and I was very
upset whenever I saw a mine uh like a
minority construction worker I was like
oh my God no they all have to look like
me you know I had that was a secondary
that was a primary concern the the all
the other things about safety and
whether the product was so that was just
that was not as important this is the
problem with catering to the woke they
don't have time for real problems so
they chase these completely made up once
trained derails or a plane crashes but
they worry about the white construction
worker offending somebody who doesn't
exist I don't believe a single person
has ever expressed a problem about a
construction worker's skin color unless
it was another skincare another
construction worker but this is the if
you want to talk about a a toxic spill
look at what look at wokism and what
what what politics is doing to every
part of life I mean it's injecting race
into everything including our buildings
and our infrastructure our
infrastructure is now racist
you know Geraldo there are more than a
thousand trained derailments a year in
this country and the truth is that I
looked into what was on this train and
in addition to the cancer-causing
hazardous waste that they had hazardous
materials they also had frozen food uh
they had Seminola which is wheat and
there was no requirement to even notify
uh this the state that there was
hazardous waste there's a trained
derailment several every day 1700 in the
country every year the main reason
broken rails
people to judge is the most
disappointing member of President
Biden's cabinet I I don't mean to make
it at home I don't mean to make an
attack on him but where the hell was he
for the baby formula where was he for
the supply chain uh disaster you know
where where is he when he wanted to be
president
uh he got accused of racism early on in
his career so now everything is about
race to to Greg's point but in terms of
the the job of Transportation secretary
that's a that's a hard hat job he should
be where the action is if the airports
are getting all screwed up he should be
at the airport he should at least
symbolically be there to express the
concern of the federal government it is
absurd I live in Cleveland 80 miles from
what you're looking at uh Pittsburgh's
50 miles away the first thing Eric asked
me is what's the prevailing wind is it
going to blow this way are we going to
have this final chlorides no joke it's
like World War One poison gas you've got
to really be very very careful about it
they uh put a judge uh you know to me he
is very very disappointing and I hate to
say it everything is Race Matters but
everything is not about race my brother
Wilfredo my late brother was the first
Puerto Rican steam fitter in local one
in New York he put this sprinkler system
in the World Trade Center they were
working on the police headquarters uh
when the planes hit the World Trade
Center I know about unions if the
Democrats are serious about integrating
construction work and and related
Industries they should go to the
Democratic unions and they should be the
people who are in the Vanguard of
integration uh you know and to make a
fuss about it without any specifics it
just it is so insulting to the people of
Ohio particularly but that black smoke
is for real what if you're looking at
your own window and you're looking at
that and you're wondering where's your
kid and your frog just died and you fish
your belly up and you know it's pathetic
I think that this is really and and it
got too little attention and if
hazardous chemicals got into the water
and killed the fish how in the world can
the EPA say that the water is really
safe and then what are the long-term
impacts or effects as the water the
tribute of a river continue to go
Southward the Ohio river flows through
Pennsylvania Kentucky Missouri Louisiana
Georgia
you can't believe what the EPA tells you
because industry Stacks the EPA with
industry hacks and that's how it's had a
bunch of tree huggers at the EPA it's a
bunch of cover-up artists
the only reason people cared about the
story in the first place because animals
were dying as our country's so funny you
show a picture of dead fish dead
chickens dead birds oh my God dead
whales oh my God fish are dying rabbits
are dying and then all of a sudden judge
they told us to stay inside for a year
because of covet because of people that
most 99 got a runny nose
is a toxic wmd goes off or they're like
I go back to work they declared a
National Emergency for monkey pox monkey
pox go back to work he doesn't shoot a
Chinese pie balloon out of the sky over
Montana he's worried about the debris
might hit someone attack pow what is a
toxic explosion in the state of Ohio
it's fine kids are going back to school
don't worry about it they have to haul
these guys the EPA mayor Pete the people
that run these trains they Splash so
much money over these politicians I
looked at their donations every
politician in America took money from
this train company they got this whole
place wired so they got to haul them in
and they have to be accountable and pay
chemical reparations to this entire town
or County because everyone's going to
have cancer in 20 years I wonder if Joe
had a key to that train yeah
the guy talks about trains and I thought
you can't you can't stop talking about
trains until one basically goes off the
rails it's gonna kill everybody and now
he's nowhere to be found and I wonder
how many lobbyists were involved in the
legislation that says yo if you only
have this percentage of hazardous waste
you don't have to alert the state that
you have bills regulations in three
straight administrations exactly it's a
powerful company exactly I went on Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now